it doesn't take a magic wand to
transform an actor into a character
whose look is memorable and meaningful
to the story all it takes are this
year's nominees for achievement in
makeup and hairstyling border young
Lindstrom and Pamela gold honor Mary
Queen of Scots
Jenny shirk or mark Pilcher and Jessica
Brooks vise greg cannom kate visco and
patricia - Haley and the Oscar goes to
greg cannom kate Bisco and Patricia de
handy device
[Applause]
the first Oscar and nomination for Kate
this going
Patricia de Haney the fourth Oscar in
10th nomination for greg cannom
Oscar's in this category have been
awarded since 1981
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Adam Poorna our great director
Adam McKay Christian Bale what a plan
Plan B Gary Sanchez the voting Academy
members and our fellow nominees from the
UK and Sweden thank you
Christian Bale fantastic we're so great
to work with and create with and
everything thank you Amy Adams thank you
for bringing us up to your level of
commitment Senate Sam Rockwell and the
150 others say members great job
Susan Matheson chef Waxman and Jennifer
matalava our DP Greg Frazier rs.50
and Paula Williams Jamie Kalman a
dreamer Oh Leslie Wofford miss Tina Walt
Chris Gallagher
Niemeyer Eric corn Brian wait
[Music]